وردنا قبل قليل استشهاد الزميل سامر ابو
مصور الجزيره سامر
ابو سامر كان يزعج سامر كان
يزع الصليب نسكم الصليب خلي حدا يجيبه
اسبوع عنوانه حرب ممنهجه على رسل الصوره
والكلمه اتسعت قائمه الشهداء الصحفيين
بينهم الجزيره سامر ابو دقه العافيه
الصحفي الزملاء الففف عافيه وفقدت غزه
ايضا صوت ميدان المعلق الصوتي عبد الله
علوان وما الدهر الا جامع
ومفرق وما الناس الا
راجل
[موسيقى]
ومودع
عادت وتيره المجازر في غزه الى ذروتها 50
شهيدا و50 مفقودا في ضربه واحده على حي
الرمال واكثر من 25 شهيدا في مجزره اخرى
في الحي الاوروبي جنوب شرق خان يونس
وتجاوزت حصيله شهداء غزه هذا الاسبوع 20
الفا منهم 8000 طفل
و61 امراه وبلغ عدد المفقودين
6700 ووثق المكتب الحكومي 1700 مجزره
ارتكبها الاحتلال طوال 75 يوما وتسببت
الحرب بنزوح اكثر من مليون و800 ال شخص
واصبح مليونان و400 الف انسان يعانون من
اجل توفير الغذاء والدواء والماء النظيف
وبحسب تقييم للاستخبارات الوطنيه
الامريكيه القت اسرائيل
29000 قذيفه ارض جو ونفذ سلاح الجو اكثر
من 500 غاره جويه خلال سته ايام معكم عبود
الاسير المحرر كنا ماسوريني اخوان يمكن
اخذونا ست سبع ساعات معهم اخذونا جوله هيك
برمائيه واتجهت الانظار في الايام الماضيه
الى فاجعه مستشفى كمال عدوان في بيت لاهيه
حيث دفنت الجرافات الاسرائيليه عشرات
النازحين والمرضى والجرحى وهم احياء داخل
المستشفى وطالبت وزاره الصحه في غزه
والمرصد الاورو متوسطي لحقوق الانسان بفتح
تقيق دولي مستقل في احداث
المستشفى الله اكبر ولله
الحمد غزه التي تعيش اسوا ايامها بسبب
العدوان الاسرائيلي تحولت الى كابوس لقوات
الاحتلال اذ ارتفع عدد قتلى الجنود
والضباط في الهجوم البري الى
137 ضابطا وجنديا وخسر الاحتلال ربع قوات
لواء جولاني بعد مقتل 822 من مقاتليه خلال
العدوان صحيفه يدعوت احرونوت الاسرائيليه
ذكرت ان مراكز اعاده تاهيل المعاقين ليست
مستعده لمواجهه الاعداد الكبيره من جرحى
الجيش الاسرائيلي وتلقت اسرائيل ضربات
نوعيه لدعائها الحربيه الاولى كانت باعدام
جنود الاحتلال ثلاثه اسرى اسرائيليين
بمنطقه الشجاعيه رغم انهم لوحوا برايات
بيضاء وخاطبوا الجنود بالعبريه بانهم
اسرائيليون و عباره انقذونا واثارت هذه
الحادثه تداعيات كبيره ودفعت اهالي الاسرى
وداعميهم الى الخروج في تظاهرات مطالبه
بوقف الحرب وعقد صفقه للافراج عن الاسرى
اما الضربه الثانيه فكانت في بث كتائب
القسام مشاهد غير
مسبوقه تظهر خسائر الاحتلال من كاميرات
مثبت على خوذ الجنود الاسرائيليين انفسهم
ندخل في البعد
التحليلي من اخذ هذه اللقطات وهذه
الصور تم الوصول له قتله والحصول على
الكاميرا وبالتالي الجيش الاسرائيلي لم
ينشرها ولن ينشرها ومن ميدان المعارك الى
اروقه الحكم في تل ابيب حيث تتسع هوه
الخلافات بين العسكريين والسياسيين حول
حرب غزه فبعد اكثر من 75 يوما على الحرب
ما تزال التقديرات الاسرائيليه تعترف
باخفاء العمل العسكري في المساس بقاده
حماس ولعل رئيس اركان الجيش هرسي هليفي
اكثر المتشائمين بتحقيق الاهداف التي
اعلنتها حكومه نتنياهو اذ كشفت صحيفه
معاريف ان هاليفي تعرض لانتقادات حاده من
وزراء اليمين بعد تصريحه بان اغتيال قائد
حماس في غزه يحيى السنوار سيستغرق اقل ققل
من عشر سنوات وفي خضم هذا التخبط العسكري
والضغوط الاقتصاديه المرتقبه بعد توقف شبه
كامل لحركه الشحن الدولي في البحر الاحمر
تسعى اسرائيل مجددا للخيار الدبلوماسي فقد
كشفت هيئه البث الاسرائيليه ان تل ابيب
اقترحت صفقه للافراج عن الرهائن لكن حركه
حماس ترفض مناقشتها دون وقف كامل لاطلاق
النار وقف يحظى بتاييد اقليمي ودولي واسع
وترفضه حكومه نتنياهو الذي يدرك ان نهايه
الحرب تعني نهايه مسيرته
السياسيه ممخ
بملف
تخس